Thomas of the session talking about and
true he'll be telling us about more
efficient methods for generating NTR you
trapdoors and Thomas Cornyn of the NCC
group Thomas taken away for is yours
okay so you throw just few minutes or
hours are good presentation from the
other Thomas and this specific talk was
motivated by cycle which is accommodate
to the post company's past contain
competition and it has an interview
latest and it requires other what we
could complete basis the state of jihad
for interior lattices with a complete
basis was from Times of India you sign
and the generation required a lot of run
and was unsuitable for small computing
distance so this talk explains how we
could make it fit on micro controls
oh the outline I will first again I have
a few sites about entire you lattices
but since you were all this morning
listening to the other Tomas you already
know everything which is in that so it
will just serve as a way to present the
notation I am using and in particular I
have don't have really implementations
view of things so the lens algebra and
more implementation issues here
so I will put on some of the two to tell
me it's 350 mg d Baba is new explains
some algebra still reduce terms of
putting on your and then I will present
the cassock in tau solver and why it
works and why it's you did a lot of
computing resources and then I'll show
how to use some nifty equation games
which have an algebraic interpretation
and speed gnomes that's low Earth to
save a lot of space and we could improve
it by a factor of more than 100 which is
nothing reachable but there are two
articles linked here the first one is
dedicated to the entire you keeping a
generation and it was published on
pickasee last year and it's coated with
the adult mass so and the second one is
just only quint and it's an
implementational oriented report on the
implementation of falcon on small
microcontroller with constant encode so
these are the two relevant sources for
what i'm explained here so integral ADC
is in these two are all about
polynomials for polynomial which we
first you the money polynomial which is
a modulus which is fine and then for any
polynomial take a module file we can
interpret it as a matrix
[ __ ] econometrics estimate sale its
into nice mark because it preserved
addition and multiplication that is the
map of the sum of two polynomials is the
sum of the maps of the
to bring on yours and the same for the
pollutes so what does means is that we
can use bring on yours and forget
everything about matrices we know that
there's a lattice somewhere in there and
for most of the talk we will ignore the
fact that there is a lattice
the entire I do a question I need about
given to small X Mooji polynomials
module file with integer coefficients
finding two other polynomials which are
also with integer coefficients and
modulo file G big Elsa that fulfill this
equation F J equals to some given
integer q q is usually small in Falcon
it's a final integer in what I explained
is that needs to be climb but in any
case it's given and we have to notice
here it's multiplication continuing with
integers as coefficients not modular
integers there are conceptually ungood
indeed and most of our troubles are
because they can become quite large so
solving the integral equation is needed
in order to get this that is if we have
a solution to the entire equation and F
G big G of small coefficients with some
notion of small and then and also there
is an extra panel H which is alpha G
over F will unify and what you do to
this time then we have two matrices in
the matrix interpretations that are
basis for the same lattice of dimension
2 m and matrix on the left is a private
key and the matrix on the right is a
pivot but the one on the left are all
its elements are much smaller than the
one of the right and in the original
entire you for encryption or near the
top heart was needed for the algorithm
to work so generating two FNG small
inner was easy but for until you sign
and also far card and other algorithms
we need complete basis that is
also to the big G and big s and all of
the program is finding the genie X when
the kind of cycle the degree of Phi is
512 or 1024 and is a power of two in the
first version of Falcon we also used
order of size for the cyclotomic
polynomials and we removed it because
there was no clear advantage to doing so
but the were clear disadvantages than me
that it makes your code a lot more
context like 3 times larger so we
simplify things
q is that value which is climb which is
1 plus multiple of 2048 and the
coefficient of the small going on nolza
less than 20 you will in fact out close
to the row with the Gaussian
distribution so in practice you'll see a
lot are between minus 5 and plus 5 and
for the big FBG there are slightly
larger but you'll fit on one bytes each
well these are small coefficient
and that file is a 2n still to me to New
York it's available over two weeks and
we don't really use that fact except for
the algebraic implemented better
algebraic interpretation of things so
here is a toy example and I'm reducing
the degree to eight judge so that it
fits on slides and when you will you two
degree the coefficients of F and G can
become a bit larger and the order that's
why we can see things like minus 55
which is definitely larger than 20 but
anyway you read small coefficient else
small polynomial F and G and you are you
is a solution to thank our equation will
be given DG but that the solution of the
entire equation is not usually not
unique I mean you have many solution to
the entire equation and even if we speak
to small solutions there may be several
choices we don't really care which one
we get everyone is fine enough for
proposition Thomas a question is
commonplace so you have a little F
little G and then big F big G which are
somewhat larger than there are little
siblings you know usually I think of a
good basis as all the vectors are
roughly the same norm that's that's not
the case here they're off by a some
factor is that okay because you're going
to be doing gram-schmidt or are you just
satisfied with the length of big f and
big G okay when doing the key
illumination they read a threshold to
meet and if we find a big f and big G
which are above the threshold we just
scrub the small X and small G and start
again
and while the threshold is enough is
some third cone magic that I do not
fully understand but do Thomas note so
he told me this is the
and I just twist him I'm not entirely
sure why that okay sure I guess you
could you could say that if you wanted
to
you might target a little left little G
big F big G all being roughly the same
size is it possible to do that or do you
have to have some some gap between their
sizes
[ __ ] they are about the same size but
when we go small enough
I mean usually big f and g are the
coefficient out no more than two or
three bits larger than the coefficients
of small F smudgy so when there are
thousands of beats loud there are thirty
good sounds of same size when we are at
the end of the algorithm and we have
small coefficient there are about that
and we use Bobby's new explain and
that's about the best that he can do in
that case okay so another question so
you know the coefficients of F and G are
they chosen from discrete Gaussian in
Falcon or uniformly and for gia or
discrete Gaussian and it went along zero
and it had specific distribution yes
which was the Sigma thing that Tomas was
talking about so the Sigma is larger
when we have a small degree like here
with degree 8 and we see here that the H
which is modulo Q that time our
coefficients which are larger than FNG
and it's part of the public key which
makes up one of the two that we need to
use is the discrete Fourier transform
and we saw all about it already this
morning the so it's basically a
bijection between two representation of
the same polynomial there is a
convenient property which must be
pointed out here which is that if versus
polynomial is real
it could add complex coefficient but if
all the coefficients are real numbers
then the the application of F over one
of the root of the fight when you're is
equaled with the conjugate of the
application over one of Alderwood that
either enter the full distance from
representation and complex numbers is
redundant we can store only hard or the
color of the numbers and we can still do
all the computations we need and this is
convenient equals if we start with n
real numbers and we can replace that
with n over two complex numbers each
with the real and imaginary part and it
take the same size so we are talking
about a transform which is in place in
104 freakin 1024 that's 1024
floating-point value so 8 kilobytes and
since we are targeting microcontrollers
with something like 60 kilobytes as one
the difference between 8 and 16
kilobytes is very significant
so the fast Fourier transform is the way
to go to the Fourier transform discrete
Fourier transform representation and
back in n log n operations it's it's
well-known and in implementation we use
or whether big reversal indexing because
it's minimized L the data
well the entity is the same thing except
everything is different because we're
computing modulo small point P small
meaning anytime P will work in practice
with yours times smaller than 32 bits so
we need a kind piece a tight 5 speeds
over DP so that guitar and woods and we
can evaluate the trinomial with integer
coefficient of all these woods and is
done modulo P and then again it's n log
n operations so for trying to spit over
DP we need P to be equal to 1 when you
wrote to N in the case of osteotomy
polynomial and there are many small
clients which are convenient for that
and they are not where we got shot of
course the entity in n log N and it's
efficient under its compatible with
computation over integer that is it can
be Express us we think when you will be
and it still works
even though the roots of thigh over ZP
are about nothing to do with the woods
of thigh over convexity complex numbers
another tool which is bad eyes nearly
Spain is another thing that is for my
point of view a bit of the skewing magic
which I do not have to understand
because as me that it works and it works
it's a fooling way we first define the
adjoint which is the polynomial which
leaves the conjugates were evaluated
over the woods of fire and it had it has
the following property which shall eat
the tool coefficient is a viewer
coefficient and the adjoint also has
real coefficients and they are easy to
compute till we just reverse the order
of most of them and negates mass of them
and that works with low numbers that
also worked with integers that also
works with modulo P that is if I take a
polynomial X with integer coefficients
and I'll take its adjoint I can do all
the computation well you know any small
point P and it will still work hold
I do hear the translation but I know
Spain with these tools and to my state
was putting on yours is that if I have a
solution to 20 on your equation and I
subtract from big f and big G a multiple
of small elephants emoji respective
business still have another solution
under multiple many multiple by a
polynomial with integer coefficient buys
new expense tells me which crayfish
which printer should use
I should compute this peculiar
expression which involved a Jones under
division and it will need a polynomial
with rule and even rational coefficients
and I have to wind it to the each
coefficient to the nearest integer and
it's not completely guarantee that one
doing it once we need the smallest
solution that I can hopeful with
politely respect writer can apply it
repeatedly moreover this wounding is an
approximation and I am allowed to be
more approximate less precise but that
in practice as integer division I will
have to resort to floating portal we
know that floating-point a limited
precision what I'm doing
that I first approximate the FNG with
floating point numbers but it with some
degree of precision the readers kidding
I have to use the scaling coefficient so
that the values are we presentable as
floating point numbers because floating
point numbers as a limited range its to
to some exponent and the exponent cannot
go beyond 1024 but
in the computations that will do the F
and G which I will work over may go much
beyond that much
I don't in ameri big F and big G and
then I conclude with the floating point
value and that's with divisions from
using the f50 so that the division can
be done very efficient basis then I am
doing your wounding and yet katie'll
which is approximate and will very small
integer coefficients I learned for them
to fit about on 25 bit
and when I do that one wound will reduce
big FM big G value about 25 bits and I
will have to do it repeatedly in order
to make them small enough but it works
well it's like shave giggles would go
over the line
so if final tool that I need now but
it's a question
okay and the question is
attention do you have [ __ ] for
multiplication JP x over 5
if you cannot choose P such as P is
equal to 1 modulo 2 N and therefore
cannot use NTT you can do it with a
schoolbook way but then it will be
quadratic in the degree you can also use
karatsuba and then you will get when you
multiply to 1024 bits polynomials
together in 3 multiplication of
polynomials of a size or 9:39
multiplication of the quarter-sized
twenty-seven multiplication of eight
side and so on
it's less convenient not only because
it's slower but also because it will
require some extra temporary reference
so you increase the RAM usage but
usually you don't want but in what I
will explain you of many small plans
that you can choose for and you have
sufficiently many that the question does
not arise back to a wizard turned and
the wizard turned in an algebraic
property in fact it's simpler
definitions one of them in the
Silverstone matrix and the other one
which shall we do it here is resultant
of two cleaners a and B is that equal is
a product of application of B over all
roots of a little skating coefficient
and it's equal to the product of
application of a over all roots of e
with another skin coefficient and
there's a lot of theory about it to the
important point here is that if you
start with two coefficient with integer
division two polynomial with integer
coefficients the resultant will be an
integer and if you apply the extended
Oakley and GCD algorithm but sticking on
integers and the pallino nodes are
cooked line as polynomials then you'll
get not one but putting on your degree
zero which will be equal to the
resultant an equivalent weight we see
that to express that is that when you do
the extremely you can GCD with with your
prisoners that working with rational you
can arrange for the GCD to be one that
is unitary polynomial but to do that you
need to perform some divisions and then
the visual coefficient u and V that you
get our point on yours with non integer
coefficients
but multiplying them by the resultant
will lead integer so in a sense the
wizard turned is characterized in the
extension of denominators while using
fractions in the classical method we are
using all update so we want to solve the
entire equation so we first use extended
euclidean GCD algorithm on polynomials
and you get all the extra polynomials we
do it twice once to get the resultant of
side is alpha and the other the
resultant of G with fine fine with G
okay so when you have the question that
that means is that s is almost inverse
of polynomial F module file almost
because the product is not one it's an
integer but individual terms and then
for G the S Prime and T Prime you can
forget them because you won't you will
them but s and T will be used
note that you have ways to Kathy inverse
small a transpose G you can use again
the extended okay congested ago
edematous time on integers over the two
wizard turns and then you get to be took
the visual coefficients that yield the
linear combination which equals true the
GCD which returns first with internal
times you with secondary time times B
it's the GCD Delta if you are looking
Delta divides you because if Delta is
not a divisor of your target fuel then
there won't be any solution you can
scrub the F and G and start over but if
the real distribution and then you can
have full solution to the entire
equation it's a solution with a fish
with big coefficients there very natural
is not a suitable solution but then you
can apply batter is no restraint to make
big f and agree much smaller so I've
worked out in my twenty kampol would
that eats so we're back to degree eight
it's a toy example small F resultant of
final F is a relatively large integer so
this needs s the first coefficient and
we have the coup d etat small F by s is
equal to the resultant when taken
material side so you can trust me you
can't recharge it works we do the same
for G another which you turned small t
another wizard
well now we have our s and T polynomials
we've got a two way certain so we it
turns out that the two resistance R
climb to each other so that G C is 1 so
1 will be with the visa of our target
you whatever the QE once but in this
case Q is twelve thousand two hundred
eighty-nine
and from that we can get a big f and the
big G and if you input that in your
favorite symbolic calculation software
you can verify that this is a correct
solution to the entire equation but of
course it's a solution with big
coefficients so now we ask the PI's
newest thing to compute the the cake
polynomial to wounding of a polynomial
with non integer coefficients so here I
write only the result of the wounding
and applying the reaction we get those
big f and big G with reasonably small
coefficients which in this scale are
sufficiently small
now this should in fact where the
problem is we've got coefficients with a
large degree and large coefficients so
we if we try to do that with back on
1024 the smooth S&T will turn out to be
about 6,200 bits each coefficient and
there are 1,024 of such coefficient for
s and another 1040 and after applying
the visual coefficient from the segunda
will be extremely dokyun GCD over the
wizard that we end up with be given D G
which will be about 13,000 bits per
coefficient so the total size just to
have that in one is about three point
three megabytes and three point three
megabytes will not fit in a small micro
controller because we want to be able to
fit in embedded system with 64 kilobyte
of one or less Thomas yes yeah a
question in the calculation you just
showed the you do the resultant of F
with Phi and the resultant of G with Phi
how are these related to the field norm
of F and G are they the same thing or
yes but in a couple of slides on you
okay dominated yes absolutely
a graphical representation because I
find it useful to have a mental picture
when thinking about things here is a
graphical representation of F and G
horizontally each is a polynomial and
the height of each box we present the
size of the coefficient so we've got
your 2d create two polynomials and the
coefficients are small but when we apply
the classic and here solver to get the
bigger fan big G we get this so the
screen is covered which means many
coefficients which are big and then bad
Eisner explains will reduce them to a
smaller size and at the end everything
fits in relatively low one but the
intermediate values are launched and
that's what we want to solve so what we
are going to do is to use degree adding
which we already saw because it's also
something you have in the phenom and in
safety into a butterfly and so on here
is how I thought about it it's witty
honks I mean thinking about where
coefficient go when implementing the
computation the idea is that if you have
if I is such that all these coefficients
all nonzero coefficients of an even
index then you can imagine a polynomial
and be with all's value this one with
all the odd index coefficient to 0 and
it's equivalent to not having the force
that is to computing modulo the heart
degree polynomial and with all the all's
we moved in that stance little you can
move between the art degree the sampling
of notes back with resume for each odd
index coefficient so it works with other
divisions and too but here we present
everything about just adding the degree
which is the most efficient situation
and of course if we start with a new
power of two we can do that repeatedly
so we thought is a question with the
other two from the other Tomas if we
take a pre-nominal
X and we can separate the even
coefficient and the odd coefficients
which in fact is expressed as using two
sub polynomials in the art degree that
is modulo X power n over 2 plus one
which I could Fe add even an expo as odd
and then we can express another
polynomial which I call a spline which
is the same except that the coefficient
with adding index have been negative and
if I multiply F with X Prime the thing
simplify out and I get X square minus X
square that if I can get the product to
be the image of large degree polynomial
or set equivalently the product will
have all its on hold its but index
coefficients equal to zero now this is
entirely with the hands these are an
algebraic expression which is the fit
norm to talk about the field known you
need a field that hill you would have to
be over rationals Q of X over X to the n
plus 1 so that Q either field and X to
the n plus 1 is irreducible all the
while you don't get a feeling if you do
not have feel you know toggle flip no
we've got something which is similar but
it's not real field and all but the
point of using just the complication
with the hands is to show that it does
not actually require us to work with a
field it works when we work with
integers it also works when we work
modulo a small point P if
if the thigh polynomial is not available
organs in P
and it turns out and apparently to known
fact Matt I did not know that that if
you compute the resultant of side with X
it's exactly the same value at the
widget and of fit normal eggs with the
heart degree side and you can do that
repeatedly so this can lead to an
efficient shipment wisdom to compute
result ins it's not the solution is that
it will not tell what we see exactly the
reduction in one side but it's an
important step in finding the actual
algorithm so we
hard to hear we noticed something which
is also convenient which is that Phil
Nam works well with the entity that is
it's no longer fit what we're going to
do things no your pee yes no question
okay so we're going to do things modulo
P but if we go to entity representation
then the entity representation of n of s
is easily obtained by multiplying their
words the coefficients of the entity of
vegetation of s and so if you want to
apply that repeatedly to get down to the
smallest degree which is one would just
have to multiply old with all in amount
of the entity of presentation together
and it would just work so this means
that if you want the so if you want to
compute the resultant of side with the
prenup F with integer coefficient n you
can do that no you do many small clients
and for each mole time you're going to
choose small x where the entity works
well that is small time speed to just be
equal to 1 modulo and so you reduce your
salt polynomial modulo P you compute
identity or plantation you multiply
order coefficient together and that's
the resultant module that's more tightly
and when you have enough of them you can
use the Chinese remainder theorem to
reveal the resultant so this does not
improve things really in our cases in
our case but it presents important tools
also AM you are not talking about how to
know that you are viewed sufficiently
many small points this will be explained
a bit later on
from that fast with your talent
the the important remark something which
form I can't tell you what important
that maybe it's trivial from the point
of your people who do more math than me
but the important part here is that it's
a product that it to get the Phenom you
multiply F by another polynomial which
is easy your tanks on ads so here I
introduced a few extra notation because
we are going to jump between degrees so
I'm just representing underst economy as
with an index which is the norm of the
one with double degree attain 4G so what
a word here is exactly what I wrote here
at the same thing so we know that when
we go to the degree and equal to one
that's X is one and we know that
applying the feet normal
the gnome which is a phenom when you
have feet repeated be a concerns the
resultant when I will support that
we have a solution for the up degree
that is for X and G and and we have a
solution for X n over 2 GN over to do
with the entire rule equation then from
that tribution we can easily compute a
new solution with the grain and it just
works and it's it uses the fact that in
fact the norm is that'll produce so they
they just group as it should now with
that we have a recursive algorithm for
finding the solution that is we go to
jab degree we could shipping doctor
yourself to get distribution 48 degree
then infer solution to the router degree
if we just do that you won't solve the
size problem you'll still get the
solution with big blue moon nodes with
very big coefficients but now oh it's
been speaking to a number of recursive
invocations so you will have occasion to
apply the buys new is based algorithm
which is point to here this is the
wicked sip server you start with F n
small F and small G if you will get
degree 1 then it's a matter of the using
the extended GCD on integers and you
just apply it you get a solution which
will be in fact about the same size of F
and G otherwise you apply the sort of
the norm
you can yourself recursively on the
degree from the solution in fact all
solution with big coefficient and then
you apply the PI's newest pain to reduce
attribution to make it about to make the
big f and be given the same size of more
advanced mangy graphically
start small - small G then you apply the
fitting on to get to the art degree when
you go to your big wheel the
coefficients will be about twice bigger
but how - many for the total size of
these art degree F and G has not changed
and we do that again and again so here
starting with eight now that the
polynomial of degree zero and n is equal
to one
all these are integers using the
extended Euclidean Jessie they're golden
you get this so the big f and Billy are
slightly larger than the small F and
small G because they have to
multiplication by 2 and then you apply
the linear spring - even we do that so
you end up with big f and big G which
are about the same size or small
advanced monkey with maybe two extra
bits and then when you go back from the
recursion this time of applying turning
that solution that degree 1 into a
solution of degree 2 will make the text
bigger and big G point larger about
three times the size of smaller than
smoothly but the linear span will be
efficient and will we do that to about
the same size at energy and then you go
up and up and you end up with the
solution and keep you try to do it
graphically with real ducks you never
touch a large part of the side which
means there is a large part of the one
that you are not using this is only with
degree AIDS but with the larger degree
the savings are significant but it the
3.3 media bites has become less than 30
kilo bytes so it's 150 15 times smaller
so now it can fit in a microcontroller
and other balloons it's also 100 times
faster so we won't mind it was not the
primary optimization but it's it's nice
nonetheless so now it can fix on
fit on an uncle Tex and full complete KP
generation with me 170 million cycles
for 512 underemployed with using it was
clocked at 168 million stool we're
talking about one second and for the
double size ficon long-term security
it's about three seconds no of course
I'm running out of time so I mean try to
go faster and when we took an agreement
ation we wanted to have a secure
implementation so this mean Constantine
when Constantine means the movie access
pattern should not depend on secret
value and in particular the length
the exact length in bits of any
individual coefficient should remain
hidden well there is a strong an
important consumer here which is that
it's for cable generation and we are
allowed to failure that is we may have a
small X and small G which would yield a
computable solution but it's not a
problem if we reject a small proportion
of valid valid cable because we can
judge generate a new one as long as we
do not reduce too much the space of
possible kid we are not losing any
significant internal part of our
security so in practice with always
friction in fact I'm building one bit of
that is half of the potential kita
annually rejected which is not that bad
and since we are allowed to fail we can
use a fixed size preferred with a good
size until we can measure the average
sized in bits of the maximum coefficient
of all value that all steps of the
computation and then we take six times
the standard deviation so here for
example the visual term preferred I can
say okay I can use a thicker than 450
behind the
and it will almost always be sufficient
and this one because in the end it's
easy to verify whether I got the correct
solution of the entire equation or not
who
in the course of the computation I need
to represent all my brilliant
coefficients on my polynomials and their
coefficient with multiple competing
representation and they keep jumping
from one to another so I represent
polynomials either odd limbs in basement
with the 31 the extra bit is convenient
because in portable you see I don't have
access to the Caliph lon
then I also replace this by road with
rigid you number system in which I
reduce the corner ruler but you do many
small plans which are close to the 31
but slightly below when they are reduced
modulo P I channel the entity with
sanitation so again the mantra picture
or isn't any aid other coefficients of
my polynomial after each coefficient is
represented vertically either number of
limbs in base two to the 31
oh the values of the coefficients reduce
maduro each month climber so the Chinese
remainder theorem and reducing the value
motivational plan are the two operation
that can make me let me switch between
the two representation boom isn't early
when I am in Venice with notation I have
three numbers Madeira which more plan
and I can apply the entity and inverse
entity to low multiplications to go
faster so whenever I'm trying to apply
to feed norms if and download fields I'm
going to awareness another identity
because we saw that then it's just a
matter of multiplying coefficients
pairwise
when I'm multiplying polynomials
together again using Aaron s so that all
values are modulo P but if the degree of
the polynomial sees I then I also do the
entity when it's more it's actually a
bit faster to just skip the entity and
use the normal quality Ric algorithm but
crucial experimentally the one degree 16
or 32 that symbol but it's a matter of
mirroring depends on the objector when
I'm in Aaron s sometimes I need to care
about the fact that the integers will
grow so maybe I am in awareness but with
not enough modulae so I need to go back
with an agreement of the Whammy to the
mini orientation and then we use it
again value most more coins a lot of
this operation can be done in place
including Chinese remainder theorem with
some pre computed values and in fact the
implementation will keep interleaving
with that is at many points I will add
the number of value which will be at
modulo small times but probably will
still games and back and I'm doing the
entity ingress entity as I go so there
is a lot of books on management to make
it fit under the particular bags that I
promised
since I have three competing
representations for putting on yours I
added a fourth one which is that each
coefficient when chosen modulo P is also
a Google mobile presentation because
it's that one is pretty technical
it's allows for constant time operations
addition and multiplication and and is a
relatively efficient they're more
efficient than using by a tradition in
that case it does tomatoes saving a few
clock cycles but it matters in game when
using baba is no explaining
unfortunately you have to use floating
point and floating point is not
necessarily constant time on any given
object context and for it's not constant
times not there it's actually missing
there's no H to you with the precision
we need so it has to be emulated with
integer code in practice using the
emulator odds rules things down but not
that much that is even of a big PC you
just may it will just take two to two
point three times more times than when
using the hardware floating point and
it's gurantee to be portable and
constant time which is nice so you can
live with floating point here it's not
that bad it may be possible to your six
point I'm working on that and the
awesome there is some extra tritanus
because you do not want to leave the
size of FNG
and in fixed point you don't have a
convenient exponent field just to store
the exponent formation final time
because I'm overwhelming my time
in the recursive algorithm whenever I go
I have computed partial F and G and I
need to remember them for when I'm
coming back from the from the recursion
so I have to store them somewhere what
if I don't store them when it works I
have to recompute them when the
recursion comebacks but it's not that
expensive comparatively I've been it has
been measured it makes the computation
about 15 persons who were but it saves
one so that's how I get under 30
kilobytes otherwise I will be around 38
kilobytes on Falcone 1024 another tricky
that in turkette of Falcone Hume is
primer and when you will prime winning
the two variable terms to be basically
coupon
ought to be both multiple of Q which is
rare because Q is plan so which it turns
out basically you want done so it's rare
that they will ask you a G C D so we can
restrict all set to the case with our
coat primer and we should change that we
can filter out quite early and when they
are bus even it's both weather turns up
even then the GCD cannot be one and it
cannot work and it turns out that if you
try to compute the resultant of side
with F modulo 2 it can mean on very
easily you just other coefficients
modulo 2 and it seems a correct value so
you can whenever you have generated
small s and smudgy and want to see
whether the to wager returns at the
deepest level revolution will both be a
van we don't take the poverty of the
sons and if they are both even then you
can reject F and G immediately this
saves track this recruit about not our
total time one third of the time so you
you gain thirty percent of the speed
Lands Act
well that
it's in the description of the algorithm
and with the unweighting that there is
the way I think about it it's all about
implementing things with polynomials
using some magical tool that I don't
fully understand any question
thank you very much
clap clap
are there any questions we have a minute
or so we can take any brief questions oh
okay I saw that there were questions and
you answered all of them so thank you
check that I answer them correctly you
can endorse or disagree welcome to deal
with reduce the coefficient of big f and
big G to the side of addiction yeah I
mean they're my invention of baba is new
explain it that it's a kind of
projection so you're projecting the big
f and big G over the small FX mod G with
the notion of multi-dimensional
projection and it will you seed the
projection to the size of the small F
and Fuji which are that on which you are
projecting so that's how I think about
it and I'm pretty sure this is not a
right way to think about it but in
practice it works that way okay are
there any other questions all right we
should someone should play the e the
left track for the applause track please
so I think people should unmute to win
clapping that's the problem
[Applause]